let's let's focus on that i suppose
here's my question right america first
not isolationist obviously
right you mentioned that you know with
isis it was like this this real evil
that needed to be stopped
yeah so it's hard to know um when
america first becomes
we need to do something internationally
yeah so i so a good friend of mine
cassandra fairbanks has
been on the show before and i said you
know we look at china we look at the
uyghur camps and everything it's very
difficult what do we do
we don't want war or we don't want to
just go and fight this massive world war
with china
and it would be catastrophic but do we
just watch as they commit atrocities
cassandra said you know she's like no
i'm anti-war 100 there's no like
tons of countries are committing
atrocities we don't get involved we we
can't just go and start war with a
massive country
and i was like what about trade
sanctions and she said well that leads
to war
so so how do we deal with them like that
right if we if we want to take care of
america first we want to be self-reliant
at what point would we intervene say
with concentration camps
yeah i think with foreign interventions
we have to have a really clear
national security objective like this
whatever it is overseas threatens
america threatens our sovereignty
threatens our ability to conduct free
and fair commerce
but there also has to be a clear end
state like we go out and we isis is a
great example we go we take out the
territorial caliphate and like then it's
mission complete
we come home we call it good we still
leave the ability to collect
intelligence occasionally strike if
needed
but we don't go over there and occupy
like there's a clear-cut objective like
with the uyghur camps and a lot of these
human rights
violations that go on throughout the
entire world
it's just a slippery slope and like so
we intervene then in china
hypothetically
where else do we intervene so my my uh
whenever the far left says like hey
anywhere there's an atrocity it's our
responsibility that responsibility to
protect doctrine that like samantha
power
and a lot of the folks in the obama
administration just love
um to that i say hey well then go sell
that to the american people and then
tell them that we need to start the
draft
because we're going to be at war
freaking everywhere because if you never
traveled outside this country i hate to
break it to you like the world's a dark
and dangerous place
how about a bill that uh whenever there
is a conflict
whenever we see an atrocity we put it up
for a national vote
yeah everybody votes and if you vote yes
you're drafted i
i would be down with that someone yeah
that was actually proposed i think
before world war ii
they're like anybody who wants to vote
for war you got to go join up yep
because you can't make someone else
fight for you
yeah i'm down because i'll tell you this
if there was something where i truly
thought we had to intervene then i'd be
the first to be like what do i need to
do right exactly like if i'm looking at
the concentration camps
in china i'll be like how can i help
obviously i don't think
frontline infantry makes sense for me
but i'll absolutely do what i can yeah
what makes sense
however i'm not absolutely convinced we
should intervene right i think assange
made a really good point
she mentioned you know there's a bunch
of countries like you know you know you
see these groups and
in in africa and nigeria what they're
doing to these young girls and
do we intervene there like don't we do
i mean that's where i'm like hey start
the draft because it's everywhere guys
exactly but i think with with uh an
actor like china or pretty much any of
these countries
um that aren't in total anarchy already
us being
the economically strongest country in
the entire world
that gives us a position of advantage so
then we can say hey china
turns out number one we don't need you
number two if you want to do business
with us
then how about you stop the genocide in
those weaker camps yeah
and until you do that we're just not
going to do business with you we could
be doing that but disney's saying thank
you
right exactly groups yeah disney and the
nba and whatever
yeah the pro wrestler guy like what was
that all about like insane
that was that's pathetic yeah that just
shows their control it's so apparently
it i don't know if it was a some some i
think might have been the movie i'm not
sure there's like an 85
revenue decrease i don't have the story
yeah in china was that fast nine
yeah so f9 i guess they're in their
revenue from chinese theaters dropped by
86
because of what he said wow you know you
know what i would do
if like if it were me i was like in a
movie and and then i said i've been a
lot of countries i've been to taiwan and
they're like
i'd be like dude if you guys are mad
whatever i don't say you have a nice day
yeah yeah exactly man like it's like am
i gonna pick and choose who's offended
who's not offended no if you're offended
well you know
sorry i guess yeah and that just shows
how much how much
how china has their fingers in every
aspect of well it's
scary it's an issue of uh
the violent tendencies of leftists or
the threat so when you look at
uh antifa versus say you know
the anti-woke classically liberal
individuals
big tech and these corporations always
side with antifa because they're the
real threat
right you know look they're not
concerned about a bunch of
intellectual dark web types you know
could you imagine like dave rubin
leading a pitchfork march to like
twitter hq and like throwing bricks
through the window right it's
not gonna happen he's gonna he's gonna
sit in his studio and he's gonna ask
people questions uh but antifa will show
up with bricks
so when an argument breaks out who's
twitter gonna side with oh yeah well
dave rubin's not gonna throw a brick at
us right so
antiva will yeah so when it comes to
china you know you can you can smack
talk in the united states people still
going to go see the movie
yeah not in china though do you
apologize to so
you apologize to china but let me ask
you this right so um
before we get into the super chats we'll
do one more uh you're in the
um the southern uh southern part of
washington the district
you're seeing to represent third and
that's that's that's the board that's
the front line
that is from washington to to oregon
right that vancouver washington the
river and then portland that's right
you're the first line of defense against
the the portland uh antifa and they're
we are they're they're violent mobs but
uh no in all seriousness
yeah what do you tell me your thoughts
on what's going on with that violence
because it does cross over into
vancouver
over there so uh i mean this is your
this is where you're seeing represent
how would you deal with this what are
your thoughts
yeah it has to be dealt with so we need
to treat antifa and blm like terrorist
organizations
like we need to use the tools of the
federal government the fbi the u.s
marshals
go after them like organized criminals
and and terrorists so we started
arresting these guys and
charging them with federal terrorism
charges that's going to take away a lot
of the incentive to go out and riot but
not
not the groups you mean the leaders the
leaders the leaders yeah
but so so let's let's let's get into the
nitty-gritty though i mean a lot of
people
do have a right to fly that flag and
speak their minds oh yeah we're not
talking about going after them
no i'm not no i mean at this point like
right now after a year
a year plus of this amount of violence
we know who the leaders of antifa are i
mean i know portland police officers and
they're like yeah i know who all the
agitators are at this point like i've
arrested them and we we have to let them
go
right you know over and over again these
are people who actively organize
violence right who and terror and terror
yeah there are a lot of people who might
fly the anti-flag of the blm flag who
don't
yeah exactly however there's there's a
very serious challenge where you get to
a point where
you know in portland for instance
they're linking arms performing a
form of human shield as people throw
explosives from behind them right at a
certain point
whether you're active in that
organization you're aiding into betting
you're investigating heroistic attacks
yeah you might not get the 10-year
federal terrorism charge but you're
going to get anything embedding and
once we start actually having
repercussions for these people the
the base of support is going to die down
a good deal i think
you know when it comes to the leaders we
absolutely need the feds to go in but
they're too occupy preoccupied with you
know january 6 or whatever
i think for the the people who are just
you know doting about
and and bumbling and providing that warm
body as a shield
you put them in in you lock up for a
weekend and actually just
charge them for you know look a lot of
these people are going to get six months
if they actually got convicted that's
not the end of the world for for any
person that's not a felony charge
that would put an end to a lot of it oh
absolutely but what happens is these
people they shall play
they're playing a game they are there
yeah so you get people who actually are
engaging in terrorist activities
i'll put it this way you know uh michael
flynn he
he made the statement we mentioned early
on in the show and we never actually
started a segment on it but
he he said uh someone asked him about a
mayanmar-style coup and he said it
should happen here and a lot of people
were like oh but he's not being serious
he has no power or he's larping and i'm
like that that's irrelevant what you
think he's doing
there are people who are cheering for
that that's dangerous like saying there
should be a military coup in here
people are going to hear that and that's
one more grain of sand so
on its own that may be fairly
significant but not the most powerful
thing ever done by any person or might
not lead to a catastrophic moment
but when you get some regular
dumb lefty type who has no idea what's
going on put on a black mask
and show they have become a grain of
sand which has made that a heap
antifa would not be able to be burning
down these buildings weren't not for
these people
right so if you know these people are
doing it or you don't i put it this way
imagine people are like hey everybody
show up at you know the the bank of
america on 7th street
we're gonna we're gonna protest and you
show up and a bunch of people put on ski
masks and go and start demanding money
and you stand there linking arms
i mean you're helping them yeah exactly
you get in trouble
exactly so uh anyway um so the leaders
who are organizing the violence yeah
we know they're doing it they're not
getting charged but what about groups
like patriot prayer because they're
they've started fights you know some of
these guys they've gone down
what what are your thoughts on that so i
think by and large there's been
some of the patriot prayer guys went
down there and they were expressing
their first amendment rights i mean if
anybody went and they assaulted somebody
then i think they should be prosecuted
too
we can't have two systems it can't be
like we prosecute the guys in the maga
hat
but then we don't prosecute the guys
burning down buildings because then you
get the situation that we have
right now where you have cities on fire
for months on end because there's no
repercussions whatsoever so i think if
you act
if if you do something illegal
regardless of who you are or
what your political affiliation is like
you should be charged for it so one of
the problems we're seeing right now is a
lot of these district attorneys
are leftists yeah so when antifa walks
in there
you know they get if they get two files
one says maga wants his antibiotics to
say maga guy prison for life antifa guy
free to go let him go yeah yep so it's
then we could look at what happened in
new york you had antifa show up to this
proud boys event they're uh harassing
people they're attacking people one guy
got robbed his backpack was stolen
and so the proud boys are leaving and
you know there's antifa
all over the place they decide they're
going to go at them
so the proud boys run at antifa when
antigua throws a bottle they get into a
fight
proud boys win kind of not surprising
but what happens then is
when when it comes to questioning by the
police antifa runs away
they refuse to cooperate the proud boys
doing the right thing
cooperate with police they got four
years in prison oh yeah and antifa
got away and no one knows who they were
right so
this is the kind of pro this is one of
the one of the problems we have in this
country it works the same way with gun
laws
you say we're gonna ban this gun okay
well the criminals don't care yeah
there's a video going around right now
they're saying it's like oh a group of
people with assault rifles and i'm like
it looks like some dudes in an urban
environment with like short barreled
full auto some sort i can't tell what it
was
i'm like yeah that's like legit hard to
get
nfa and this is how did he get that in a
city
yeah these are guys are serious regular
law abiding citizens won't have any of
that stuff
when you look at what happens with the
proud boys these guys are like yes
officer we believe in you thank you
we'll cooperate now they're in prison
the lesson here is don't cooperate with
police because you're not going to get a
fair deal or at the very least
you can see how the system works if if
you show up and do the right thing and
admit
and and give the information they lock
you up they're like yep exactly
yeah and there's just been no
repercussions whatsoever for going after
these
these terrorists essentially you know
for months on end and it's just spread
like
violence never goes goes away unchecked
if if people act violently they don't
just say one day oh hey it's the 15th of
the month let's stop being violent like
they actually have to be met with force
that's just that that's the law of
nature that's the way it has to go and
so we actually have to
put this back in the bottle by arresting
a lot of them and i think we started
arresting the leaders
in exposing who they were and how they
were being funded like we did with the
mafia back in the day
they a lot of the popular support that
these these groups are getting in places
like portland
would go away because right now they're
thriving off this whole narrative
that hey these guys are out there
fighting fascism they're fighting for
black lives
people believe this stuff people in the
suburbs of portland believe this they
donate
money they donate political support i
mean my the neighborhood i grew up in
gave almost half a million dollars to
the
the bail fund that kamala harris was
promoting to bail out people that were
burning our city down
i mean that's a level of popular
indoctrination that just
amazed me that's hard to fight but uh
but you're in a republican district
we are yeah that's really interesting
just north of portland north republican
and you got to win a primary that's
right you know the way i see it is
i've said in numerous videos segments
i've done over the past couple of months
like
why why bother voting for these
republicans when you empower people like
mitch mcconnell
what does he do i agree the republican
party in 2016 2016 and 2018 had the
ability to do stuff trump got in 2017.
they could have made some moves yep that
we we knew the censorship issue was
going to be a huge problem for all
republicans they did literally nothing
and i'm like
uninspired lindsey graham fist bumping
kamala harris on the senate floor it's
like fun inspires the same party
however if people like you get elected
you know right now i think marjorie
taylor green is like one of the only
fighters
yeah whether you like or not i'm not you
know she's had a bunch of
dumb stuff on facebook at one point but
she pushes back she fights in
very similar ways to many like like the
squad she's you know fantastic she's
loud she pushes back
and so i'm not saying you know if if
congress was
entirely comprised of just the clones of
martial telegram be a good thing right
but you need people who are not part of
the establishment
who are going to vote against the stuff
there's i look at the two parties and
there's like you know after tulsi
gabbard left them not convinced is a
good democrat anymore
yeah and i disagree with her on some
policy issues but i i think she was
honest
she was honest she was trying and i look
at the republican party and i'm like
maybe 10
10 republicans yeah there's a handful
need more yeah and if you can get a lot
more in maybe in 2020 uh 2022
there will be some significant changes i
bring this up because i'm thinking about
what's going on in portland
how do you get the fbi to actually deal
with these people well you need some
political power
you do the republicans will need to
control the house probably and the
senate ideally yeah
and not only that you sell to go you
still have the issue of of biden but
then you can do more committee hearings
you can do commitment
absolutely but you'd also need many of
those republicans to be
populist american first yeah you know
act people who are not part of the
establishment crony machine people who
actually want to see things improve
i do have a fear of encroaching
authoritarianism though
one of my fears is that antifa has acted
a fool so much
people will just say get the feds and
start locking these people right up
exactly and then you get
yeah an equal and opposite reaction
which is still not a good thing yeah
i mean it has to be done right but i
think if we treat them like a terrorist
organization or like organized crime
go after the leaders make an example out
of some of the guys that are out there
locking arms and enabling it that a lot
of it would just kind of go away
because people don't want to people
don't want to get arrested and slap for
federal terrorism charges right
you know but then there does have to be
a clear point where we bring the feds
back and i think we can also offensively
use a lot of federal funding for these
cities because ted wheeler the mayor of
portland he's let all this happen and
then kate brown the governor and then
in washington state jay inslee he's done
the same thing with seattle i don't
think those governors and mayors deserve
a penny of federal taxpayer dollars like
we send in the feds to clean up the
antifa
and after that we're like hey until you
guys start prosecuting criminals and you
take care of all these rampant
homeless and drug issues and crime
issues like you're just not getting any
more money
sorry yeah man if we called them
terrorists if we like declared antifa
terrorists would then
like their the mother of the leader of
the antiva that he lives at her
in her basement would she be implicated
for terrorist charges
no no no you you still get due process i
mean it's still the the federal
government and then you know
the fbi and the u.s marshals going in
you know
day in court you and i find fascinating
you know people genuinely don't believe
antifa is real they don't exist it's
just it's just a idea but it's because
they watch cnn right
they don't actually read the news they
don't know these things
and so they genuinely think antifa isn't
a real thing
yeah and so i see these posts on
facebook all the time where they're like
it's a meme antifa just means
anti-fascist there's no antifa group
it's not true
and then i'm like here's a list of all
the known antifa affiliates like rose
city antifa in portland
literally a group with people with
leaders with they have a website
you can sign up to join the group the
group exists it's called
there's new york city antifa there's
like salt lake city or whatever
yeah they literally just call themselves
city antifa yeah they exist they
cooperate with each other they work
when there's like if you're in between
seattle and salt lake city or whatever
they'll meet in the middle
both groups show up absolutely but they
say it's not a real thing
right and then what happens is you get
these hearings where and i don't i don't
understand where the republicans are to
push back on this stuff or
i don't know if they can do anything
anyway where they're like the biggest
threat in this country is white
supremacy
there's 10 000 of them and that's why i
like what's like the ada no no i'm sorry
the adl standard
no the adl there's like 10 000 people
yeah
how many how many active antifa are
there like substantially more oh yeah
we've seen we've seen the protests
across the country there's a lot of them
now
the worst offenders are a lot less yeah
but mass protests for a year riots
smashing up windows
yeah i think that's a much bigger threat
i suppose though when they're flying
black lives matter flags at our
embassies
of course to them the biggest threat is
white supremacist white supremacy yeah
regular americans and the left has no
incentive to go after antifun blm
because they
execute their their political policy for
them and we saw that in lighting the
cities on fire
in the the year that trump was trying to
get elected and then right now the way
that they've jumped onto this whole
palestinian issue like you see the whole
palestinian flag getting flown by
antibiotics and that's all being done
because
joe biden is screwing up the middle east
like we gave money back to iran
iran gave money to hamas boom we got a
war going again but to run cover for
that just in the same way antifun blm
brings up all these racial issues to
keep the working class distracted now we
have
antifa saying oh it's all about
palestinian liberation now that's part
of the black lives matter movement like
it's run distractions it's tribalism
yeah that's all it is because i i i went
to um
uh belfast and they have the peace wall
right from the northern ireland and on
one side it's palestine on one side it's
israel
and i asked a local i was like why why
what's with the israel-palestine thing
and it's like oh you know
the the one side thinks they're
oppressed so they associate themselves
with palestine the other side
thinks that they're the you know natural
right so they with israel and i'm like
that has nothing to do with with like
northern ireland and like yeah it's just
they identify it's like leftist causes
for one group nationalist causes for the
other group and i'm like
that's all it is yep this you know and
that's what i think i think we're seeing
a lot of that here where people
are getting into fights over israel and
palestine and and i tell you man there's
a lot of people i hear them screaming
like pro-israel
screaming pro-palestine and i'm like i
don't understand like i'm hearing the
same thing from both sides
i'm not here to equate i'm just saying
man people are really tribalistically
involved in that conflict and it's
really hard to
to to figure out thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time